welcome to my presentation on equivalent
fractions so equivalent fractions are
essentially what they sound like they're
two fractions that although they use
different numbers they actually
represent the same thing let me show you
an example let's say i had the fraction
one half
why isn't it writing
make sure i get the right color here to
add the fraction
one over two
so graphically if we were to draw that
if i had a pi
and i would have cut it into two pieces
and that's the denominator there two and
then if i were to eat one of the two
pieces
i would have eaten
one half of this pie
makes sense nothing nothing too
complicated there well what if instead
of dividing the pie into two pieces let
me just draw that same pie again
instead of dividing in two pieces what
if i divided that pie
into four pieces
so here in the denominator i have a
possibility of a total of four pi four
pieces in the pie
well and instead of eating one piece
this time i actually ate
two of the four pieces
so i ate two
out of four pieces or a two-fourths of
the pie
well if we look at these two pictures
we can see that that i've eaten the same
amount of the pie
so these fractions are the same thing
if someone told you that they ate one
half of a pie or if they told you that
they ate two-fourths of a pie
it turns out that they ate the same
amount of pie so that's why we're saying
those two fractions are equivalent
another way if we actually had let's do
another one
let's say and that pie is quite ugly but
let's assume it's the same type of pie
let's say we divided that pie into
eight pieces
and now
instead of eating two we ate four of
those eight pieces
so we ate four
out of eight pieces well we still ended
up eating the same amount of the pie we
ate half of the pie
so we see that one-half will equal
two-fourths and that equals four-eighths
now do you see a pattern here if we just
look at the numerical relationships
between one-half two-fourths and
four-eighths
well to go from one-half to two-fourths
we multiply the denominator the
denominator just as review is the the
number on the bottom of the
fraction
we multiply the denominator by two and
when you multiply the denominator by two
we also multiplied the numerator by two
we did the same thing here
and that makes sense because well if if
i double the number of pieces in the pie
then i have to eat twice as many pieces
to eat the same amount of pie
let's see let's let's let's do some more
examples of of equivalent fractions and
hopefully it'll it'll hit the point home
let me erase this
why isn't it letting me erase
something is
okay let me see erase
let me use the regular mouse
okay good good good sorry for that so
let's say i had the fraction
over 5.
well by the same principle as long as we
multiply the numerator and the
denominator the numerator and the
denominator by the same numbers we'll
get an equivalent fraction
so if we multiply the numerator times 7
and the denominator times 7
we'll get 21 because 3 times 7 is 21
over 35
and so three-fifths and 21 over 35
are equivalent fractions
and we essentially and i don't know if
you already know how to multiply
fractions but all we did is we
multiplied three-fifths times seven over
seven to get 21 over 35
and if you look at this what we're doing
here isn't magic
seven over seven well what's seven over
seven if i had seven pieces in a pie and
i were to eat seven of them i ate the
whole pie right
so seven over seven this is the same
thing as one
so all we essentially said is well
three-fifths
and we multiplied it times one
and that's
which is the same thing as seven over
seven
oh boy this thing is messing up same
thing
and that's how we got
21 over 35
so it's interesting all we did is
multiply the number by one and we know
that any number times one is still that
number and all we did is we figured out
a different way of writing 21 over 35.
so let's say if i were to
let's start with a fraction
over 12
and i wanted to write that
with the denominator
let's say i wanted to write that with
the denominator
well to go from 12 to 36 what do we have
to multiply by well 12 goes into 36
three times
so if we multiply the denominator by
three we also have to multiply the
numerator by three
times 3
we get 15.
so we get 15 over 36 is the same thing
as 5 over 12. and just going to our
original example all that's saying is if
i had a pie with 12 pieces and i ate
five of them let's say i did that and
then you had a pie the same size pie you
had a pie with 36 pieces and you ate 15
of them then we actually ate the same
amount of pie